jean eric branaa merci d'être en direct
avec nos furet france alors on a vu dans
le sujet il ya quelques secondes les
tensions que suscite cette cette
campagne est ce que la crainte de
violence est réelle dans les heures les
jours à venir selon vous je crois quand
même qu'elle est nettement exagéré qui
pas une visite aux états unis remarque
depuis quatre ans maintenant les deux
rives démocrate et républicaine se sont
éloignées l'une de l'autre il ya un vrai
gouffre entre les deux savent au
quotidien les gens ne se parlent plus
ainsi sont d'une opinion ou une autre il
y a deux vérité alternative pour chaque
information quasiment on a le côté pile
et le côté face avec des vérités très
différente tout ça est une réalité
aujourd'hui aux états unis et les
tensions extrêmes de sang même à la
limite confrontation elle votre
reportage l'expliqué de façon assez
éclatante mais on pourrait continuer on
expliquant qu'il ya eu un mort à
kanyosha notera propre à portland pour
signaler des morts des deux côtés
c'est vrai que tout cela est inquiète
mais en même temps l'élection est un
autre temps et et après l'érection
on peut en tout cas douter qu'il y aura
le catastrophisme que certains annoncent
un petit peu sur tous les temps avec des
ministes milices qui descendraient dans
la rue ça fait partie de cette histoire
des élections américaines où on en
entend réguler on parle pas là des fois
qu'il ya eu des risques de milice était
en l'an 1800 c'était l'élection de
thomas jefferson et c'est vrai qu'à ce
moment là les tensions étaient
absolument extrême avec des vrais
milices pour le coup puisque elle venait
d'être créé armé qui ont patrouillé dans
les rues et qui se confronter les uns
aux autres je doute qu'on en soit là
cette fois ci même s'il peut y avoir un
débordement à droite à gauche parce que
des gens déséquilibre il y en a partout
alors vous avez publié une fois une
biographie on lisait de joe biden alors
est ce que c'est un vrai favori est ce
qu il a les ressorts suffisant pour
faire perdre trump et lui succéder alors
absolument mais dans un premier temps
c'est
la guerre entre en campagne il est
rentré dans l'idée qu'il fallait faire
un référendum en titre up et ça tombait
bien
donald trump voulait aussi faire un
référendum trop tram pour le court donc
ils étaient au moins d'accord sur ce
point là et c'est vrai que joe biden
s'est inscrit dans un premier temps dans
l'héritage de barack obama a donc il
comptait capitaliser sur la très bonne
image de de celui qu'il avait servi
comme président donald ram fait
quasiment 90% chez ses supporteurs et
obama avec un taux de quasiment la même
chose chez les démocrates donc on avait
une lutte équilibre hebeisen essayant de
récupérer les dividendes
et puis la pandémie est passée par là
c'est le deuxième temps aujourd'hui
beaucoup de gens votent pour avoir un
président consolateur réparateur qui va
s'occuper d'eux parce qu'il y a des
vrais problèmes de santé de l'économie
d'emploi et en plus des problèmes
sociaux qui s'ajouté donc ils cherchent
quelqu'un de beaucoup plus rassurant et
d'apaiser que donald trump et dans un
troisième temps c'est vrai que le
programme qui a été construit par joe
biden à la suite de l'abandon dans la
course de bernie sanders construit
d'ailleurs avec les progressistes
puisque il avait créé huit commissions
de travail coprésidé par un progressiste
un modéré on finit par séduire même le
camp progressiste il a donc réuni le
camp démocrate qui lui a permis comme il
le fait depuis 47 ans aux politiques de
se tourner vers l'autre camp c'est un
homme de compromis
il s'est donc tourné vers républicain
c'était le plus républicain compatible
des démocrates et il a donc pu continuer
sa construction en donnant cette fois ci
au camp plus républicain ce qui rassure
même d'ailleurs dans les contrats piste
on entend régulièrement certaines
personnes qui disent qu ils donnent
après tout c'est le moins pire de tout
c'est que avec lui sera possible de
fonctionner alors arrêtons nous quelques
instants sur les swing states pourquoi
ces états vont déterminer le résultat du
scrutin
alors est ce qu'on appelle des twins
taille des tapis vaut deux et en
balançant d'irak ont beau jeu sont des
résumés des états qui sont très partagés
entre démocrates et républicains donc ça
beaucoup de leurs côtés un coup de
l'autre et la particularité cette année
c'est que les 12 états pivots ont tous
été gagné par donald trump en 2016 donc
l'impression elle est ce ses épaules il
faut qu'ils aient regagne quasiment tous
en tout cas jusqu'au gain qui l'a vu la
dernière fois c'est à dire une avance de
38 grands électeurs et justement cette
avance est tellement peu que pour le
maiden partie est assez facile à en
gagnant le whisky matinée le michigan où
il est donné très largement en avance il
suffit de gagner un sale état et il est
président des états unis
alors si l'on gagne 2 3 4 ce sera donc
une avance qui s'ajoutera c'est pour ça
qu'il est super favori aujourd'hui de
cette élection est serré les résultats
du scrutin
il ya des chances pour qu'il soit
contestée par donald trump
c'est ce qu'il nous dit mais ça fait
partie la russie du discours politique
un peu classique d'abord donné lé train
nous avait dit la même chose en 2016
qu'il contesterait qu'il avait des
fraudes il avait annoncé depuis très
longtemps en intensifiant la quatre
jours du scrutin sur cette thématique il
annoncé aussi que ces supporters
descendrait dans les rues tout ça il n'y
a rien de nouveau de ce côté là
maintenant est-ce qu'il contestera
d'abord c'est pas dans la tradition
américaine il ya eu d'été des élections
très compliqué en 1800 en 1804 entre en
1876 et puis en 1967 de kennedy ou plus
près de nous celle de 2007 expliqué dans
un reportage tout à l'heure mais à
chaque fois le candidat qui est en face
se finit par concéder la victoire et
tout rentre dans l'ordre
est-ce que donald trump ira jusqu'au
bout de la contestation c'est à dire
d'amener cela dans les différentes cours
d etat puis ensuite en cour suprême puis
ensuite de contester le résultat et
grands électeurs pour que le congrès se
saisisse
cette affaire me suis crois pas beaucoup
parce que ce serait pas une sortie
honorable
sachant que à la fin joe biden si les
sondages le confirment aura quand même
une avance assez confortable
merci beaucoup jean eric branaa rappelle
que vous êtes maître de conférences à
l'université paris ii assas spécialiste
des états unis et auteur du livre joe
biden une biographie qui vient d'être
publié aux éditions du nouveau monde